احصائيه مقلقه حول مصابين الامراض
الوراثيه للمواليد في السعوديه كشف عنها
البرنامج الوطني لفحص الامراض الوراثيه
عند المواليد في احدى الحملات التوعويه
الخاصه بالبرنامج وشارت الاحصائيه الى ان
السعوديه هي من اعلى الدول في معدلات
الاصابه بالامراض الوراثيه السبب الاكبر
زواج الاقرب
قرار خاطئ قد يجعل حياه الالاف من الاطفال
ناقصه ومليئه بالمعاناه نتيجه مرض وراثي
في السعوديه فقط تسجل اصابه واحده
بالامراض الوراثيه لكل الف مولود بمعدل
يقترب من خمسه اضعاف المعدلات العالميه
معروف ان الامراض الوراثيه المتنحيه نتيجه
زواج الاقارب تكون اكثر اذا كان اذا كان
هذا الشيء اللي هو زواج منتشر فنسبه
الامراض الوراثيه عندنا متنحيه اكثر من
دول الغرب
بالعكس حتلاقي دول غرب عندهم الامراض
المتعلقه بالكروموسومات او الامراض
السائده اكثر من المتنحيه لانه ما عندهم
زواج اقارب فنحن نعتبر من الدول التي
تنتشر فيها بكثره اللي هو الامراض
الوراثيه المتنحيه زواج الاقارب يعد سبب
الاول لارتفاع معدلات الاصابه بالامراض
الوراثيه في السعوديه ما دفع وزاره الصحه
الى تنفيذ خطه كبرى لتخصيص استشاري لكل
اسره سعوديه ضمن التجمعات الصحيه في المدن
بهدف تعزيز الوقايه الصحيه والكشف مبكرا
عن الامراض ومعالجتها احنا برنامج طبيب
لكل اسره هو برنامج يهدف لمتابعه المريض
بشكل دوري تقريبا احنا عندنا كل اسبوع
لقاء مع فريق مكون من ممرض منسق حاله
ومدرب صحي يتناقشون في حالات المرضى او
يتم التواصل معهم الهاتفيا لمتابعتهم طبعا
لمتابعه تكون عن طريق وضع خطه علاجيه اما
كان علاجيا او وقائيا
ما قبل الزواج في السعوديه لا يكشف الا عن
مرضين وراثيين من بين الاف الامراض ولم
يحقق نتيجه في الحد من الامراض الوراثيه
على الرغم من التوصيات المستمره بزياده
انواع الامراض الوراثيه التي يشملها فحص
الزواج الالزامي من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا المشرف على
البرنامج الوطني لفحص الامراض الوثائق
الوراثيه عند المواليد استشاري الوراثه
الطبي الدكتور ضياء عرفه دكتور ضياء حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه قبل عشرين سنه
تقريبا اقرت المملكه برنامج الفحص الصحي
قبل الزواج او ما سمي ببرنامج الزواج
الصحي المرحله الاولى كان عن امراض
الوراثيه الدم ثم بعد ذلك الى الامراض
الاخرى
منذ ذلك اليوم حتى اليوم يعني بعد 20 سنه
اذا ما تحدثنا عن الارقام
هل هناك زياده في اعداد المصابين بهذه
الامراض الوراثيه
من الاقارب الذين يتزوجون بالرغم من من
ايجابيه الفحوصات التي تتم في هذا
البرنامج
اولا اشكركم على الدعوه واشكر العربيه على
جهودها في نشر التوعيه بالامراض الوراثيه
بالنسبه
لفحص الزواج هو يعتني بامراض الالتهابات
الكبد الفيروس وايضا الامراض
المتوسط اللي هي منتشره عندنا بشكل كبير
برضو في المنطقه
الى حد ما
وربما يعني يمكن حالات الامراض المتعلقه
بالدم
قلت ان اول نعم قلت بكثير
لكن هناك امراض وراثيه اخرى يعني
مورث
يعني مثل
القصور الغده الدرقيه هذا مرض وراثي مثل
التليف الكيسي ليصيب
الرئه والجهاز الهضمي هذا برضو مرض ورا
مثل الضمور العضلات
برضو من امراض المنتشره عندنا مرض وراثي
نامل انه في المستقبل يكون في يعني تركيز
اكبر على
الامراض الاخرى غير امراض الدم التي بلا
شكل البرنامج نجح بشكل كبير في الحد من
انتشارها
ايش اخطر الامراض اللي ما زالت موجوده
الامراض الوراثيه دكتور لانه في حالات
كثير من اعاقات نشوفها باقارب تزوجوا وهم
في سن شاب يعني في سن صغيره ولديه اثنين
او ثلاثه يعني من هؤلاء الاطفال المصابين
بس دعني اوضح نقطه مهمه
الامراض الوراثيه بشكل عام بشكل عام ما في
لا يوجد هناك علاج جذري
ممكن ياخذوا المريض ويتم الشفاء الكامل
وتعديل وتعديل الطفره الوراثيه انما هناك
علاج مساعد
مساند علاج تاهيلي علاج وظيفي اما
العلاجات التي
يعني تكون لها فائده اكبر هي المشموله
الان في البرنامج الفحص المواليد 18 مرض
استقلابي مع مرضين في الغده في الغده
الصماء اللي هم الغده الدرقيه والغده
البار كفري
في حالات ماساويه كتير الدكتور انا اريد
ان اسال عن هذه هذه تحديدا انت تعرف انه
الفحص الزواج ملزم ويمكن يعني يوفر الكثير
من الناس الامكانيه انه ينظر لمستقبل
الزواج ومستقبل اسرته واطفاله لكن بالرغم
من ذلك التقيد بالنتيجه غير ملزمه للطرفين
بمعنى ممكن تكون النتيجه غير متوافقه
وممكن كذلك هذا التحليل او هذا الفحص وصحح
لي يعني انت المتخصص اكثر ممكن يتنبا بما
يمكن ان يحدث ومع ذلك يكون هناك يعني
اصرار من الطرفين على الزواج
الا يجب ان يتم الان اعاده النظر في هذا
الامر مراعاه لهذه يعني الحالات التي
نراها يعني مازلنا نراها بالرغم من كل هذه
البرامج
اتفق معك انه انه انه لا زالت هناك حالات
وفيها يصر الزوجان على اكمال اكمال عمليه
الزواج رغم رغم تحذيراتنا لهم ونصحنا لهم
انه ممكن يكون في اولاد
مصابين بمرض الانيمه مجانيه او بحر متوسط
انه نتائج هذا الفحص تكون صحيحه بمعنى انه
انتم ستتلقون ابناء يعني لديهم مشكله
وراثيه
هو اذا كان في علامات في التحليل المبدئي
اللي هو تحليل الدم فهم الخطوه الثانيه
انهم بيعملوا
يعملوا اللي هو
قياس لتركيز الهيموجلوبين والخاص
والبروتين الخاص بالانيمه المجاليه او
البحر المتوسط
نسبه
الدقه يعني كبيره تصل الى 90% نعم لذلك
يصر الطرف الطرفان على الزواج بالرغم من
كل نعم احنا فقط مجرد ننصح ونرشد ونوضح
للعائله انه ممكن يكون في اولاد وممكن
يكون في اصابات
ومعاناه للاهل في التنويم المتكرر لما
نقول 90% تشوف انه يجب ان يعاد في قرار
مساله
التقيد بنتيجه من الطرفين من عدمها من
المناحيه طبيه يا دكتوره
وحتى انسانيه كمان يعني
ما يعني سواء سواء الدراسات اللي احنا
درسنا فيها واول المراكز الطبيه لم يكن
هناك الزام من قبلنا كاطباء على الاهل
بانهم لا يجب ان يتزوجوا للزواج هناك
نصائح هناك ارشادات لكن كاطباء لا يمكننا
بشكل
بشكل صارم انه نخبر الاهل بعدم او او بعدم
اكمال الزواج يعني نحن مجرد ننصح ونرشد
طبعا هم يتحملوا مسؤوليه اذا كانوا حبوا
يكملوا في العمليه ام لا شكرا جزيلا لك
المشرف على برنامج الوطني عند المواليد
استشاري الورات الطبيه الدكتور ضياء اعرف